hello I am Keith Sawyer I'm a professor
of psychology and education at
washington university in st. louis and i
am a creativity researcher so what I'm
doing to to foster creativity and
innovation is focusing on the power of
teams and groups to generate creativity
in my research I find that exciting new
ideas always come from collaborative
teams but collaborative teams that are
working together in a particular way the
way that I think of as improvisational
because when people are working together
in an improvisation way it's almost like
a kind of group flow where unexpected
new ideas emerge that's where companies
find the most innovation you need to
create a context where you can have
collaborative teams generating ideas
together realizing the power of
creativity of everyone in the group